hi everybody it's kevin van oort here
and i'm with daniel DeCicco and Daniel
you are the man behind stardrive too yes
yes this is an independent games project
and I wear many hats to have made it
it's a4x and I'm excited to show you
what we've got here that's awesome so
stardrive one obviously existed before
stardrive too yeah one would assume yes
it did it's a the first one is a was a
real time for X so you know everything
happen real time as possible but you
could compress time and this for the
second iteration what we've done is
taken a more like total war approach so
we have a turn-based strategy layer
where you're making your big decisions
and then there's a tactical like
real-time battles layer right so when
your fleets meet you can that's the big
difference between one and two let's
take a look and see what you got to show
us today alright so we got cited two
modes all right there's a campaign mode
where you play like the 4x and then
there's a battle arena mode where you
can just get right to the combat if
that's what you want alright so I'll
show you the campaign mode first and
then after just kind of getting you a
feel for that and go back and have some
fun in the battle arena sounds good to
me so you have nine races to choose from
and they're all customizable so for
instance these guys have been real
popular the space bears the cool Rafi
and you know get humans got some like
playing people and you can click
customize to go into this racial
customization screen so you can use a
good point system to buy and sell good
traits and bad traits right so you can
really focus how you want your play
style to be so if you want to be like
really good at making ships or fighting
or they have a good industry or farming
then you get to pick and choose these
trades to customize that experience
there's also some things in this that
really changed like the whole way the
game plays like you can be cybernetic
which means that your people don't even
need food and you have to like construct
new citizens rather than have them
birthed so I'll just pick a kind of
straightforward I'll be the default
space bears to show you the game
then you have some galaxy setup options
you get to choose like what kind of gal
I see how many enemies how big what's
going to leave everything as default for
now so what do you say that anybody
that's played space for x games should
probably feel right at home and they
first begin they should be able to find
their way around pretty easily oh yeah
we've really made a lot of effort to
like make the game friendly and
accessible lots of tooltips everywhere
so you can just learn the game by
playing but I think anybody who's played
for us is before going to feel real
comfortable right so this is the you're
starting system you've got your starting
planet got a starting fleet here and if
we zoom out we can see like what's going
on in the galaxy you know there's a big
galaxy we don't know what's out there we
know a few like you can see a few
features that have been generated this
is like a nebula that we could go
explore some other stuff like that but
for the most part we don't know anything
about the galaxy we have our home planet
and we can go check that out and this is
your interface to where you manage your
colony and on the left side here you can
see that we've got our citizens so if
you've played master Brian to this will
be a somewhat familiar system where
you've got farmers workers and
scientists and you can just like assign
how you want your labor allocated and
throughout the game you can have
multiracial planetary civilizations so
you can get like plant people and
cybernetic bugs on your planet and stuff
and and all of them have different
traits so when you like mouse over some
of these things you can get a breakdown
for how much food they're creating be
modified by their individual Rachel
statistics so there's some some good
depth there and also some incentive to
build a multicultural civilization at
the beginning of the game you can also
you don't have a lot to build we've got
some some ships that we can build we got
just a couple buildings that we can add
in DQ I'd like to just start off by like
getting a couple of military ships under
way maybe throw another colony ship in
there just so they have something to do
while I explore the galaxy I can take a
look around my home planet or my home
system and I can see that there's
actually like this planet here is a
Tundra planet it's undergoing an ice age
which like has a few modifiers to what's
going on there has also got this spice
special resource
kind of like based on like they know
they're doing like Paula muah team so
like if you control some spice each
source that you control gives you like a
weapon damage bonus and if you actually
manage control for sources and you get
like another bonus research throughout
the empire so there's this like
strategic resource system that as we
explore the galaxy you can find all
different types of these resources and
try to control them to get the monopoly
so anyway these are look kind of
interesting but I want to start
exploring my neighborhood so I've got my
fleet here I've got two ships in it I've
got a colony ship and an exploration
forget and I'll break them up and go
explore my nearby systems so I'm giving
them some move orders and then the last
thing I'll do before I take my turn is I
can I need to choose some research so
this is the research menu and there's
six trees of research and then each tree
has a lot of depth and actually they're
the at a point to become infinite you
can just research like future tech that
gives you a small bonuses but the way
that the research works in this game is
that you're presented with sort of a
high-level thing that you can do like
offworld industry and then you have to
choose one application so you either
choose a xeno mine which is like a
production per worker sort of like a
wide Empire versus an automated Rover
Bay which gives you a flat rate
production and when I choose one I lose
the other I know it's excluded and it'll
force you into doing diplomacy to try to
trade with the other empires to pick up
the researches that you missed so as we
do a little exploration will run into
some other empires and hopefully I can
show you how that works one thing that's
interesting about the way this works is
like in a lot of games you have to turn
button there's like this crunching you
know and you wait 15 seconds and now
it's the other time and star drive to
you just hold down the spacebar to like
get turns clicking away and the whole
universe updates simultaneously so I
really wanted to make it but smooth like
quick to play so as I'm exploring a
little mouse button doesn't work here I
can see there's nothing really in this
system this I'm going to retask my
colony ship to go check out maybe the
system down here
that's going to be dangerous as I
entered this system right i found a
wormhole and big toxic planet this toxic
plant it's not very good like if i look
at the stats it like doesn't produce any
food performer you can't farm there but
these or this diamond die reise or
resource gives my ships like extra hit
points if I colonize it so nothing
really there I could really chance it
and jump through this wormhole I think
I'll do it just for the sake of the demo
here what what are the different things
that doing so might might do is that
going to put you someplace randomly
within a within a certain range yeah
it's connected to some other end I don't
know where it is and it could I could
end up in a system with some bad guys or
maybe I'll meet on a race or maybe it'll
just jump one system over we'll find out
let's do it I'm right oh yes oh so I
jumped like right into the their
territories what happened and I I met
these guys so these are this is the bull
far and I really made a lot of effort to
like do some characterization of these
guys there's so much text you can get
for each race it's all like dynamic they
all have their individual like fonts
which I just thought help like bring
them alive so anyway they say hello and
now we can go into like the this is the
diplomacy panels this is where you do
all of your interaction with other races
and just to get a concept for what's
going on here we've got their approval I
can see what their approval of me is we
just we haven't any relations they just
fifty percent no adjustments and also my
people have an approval of them that's
the same and I can look at their traits
their militarists their evil their
expansionist so like in it these traits
affect how they're going to how they're
going to deal with me as a player and
also it's like militarist I think yeah
they value like ship technologies so
when we start to get into trading we
don't actually have any technology of
trade just yet but we can make some
treaties so there's a list of stuff that
we can trade and I can start like a
trade deal with them and the way this
works is we each ad what we want to
trade to the deal you can see the values
as long as they match then you have a
good trade but it's limited by this
tolerance mechanic so like as you make
deals some of the tolerance for each
other is used up and that reset
slowly over time this it's a system that
is mentally so you can't just abuse the
diplomacy system and just keep training
and training and trading and also like
you have to like they have to like you
because as their approval goes up and
down their tolerance for you will also
adjust so you know there's a you can
really screw your relations up with with
a race if you aren't careful because
these guys will or evil they're gonna
start making demands and me pretty soon
they're going to want me to pay tribute
and stuff like that do you suppose this
also helps take away some of the the
secrecy of diplomacy systems of a lot of
games have sometimes you know here
you'll be denied and you won't have any
real understanding why they don't like
you or what what drove this particular
decision yeah I mean I'm nodding as you
speak because it's that's exactly what I
was aiming for here is it's a
predictable system and the other thing
it's like as we modify this deal you'll
see that their texts like little update
in real time so now your tribute looks
good or I can demand something more from
them you know and they just start it's
all those tell you know that's not going
to work because like we don't trust you
because it's you asked very much for us
so I really wanted this to be
transparent but right now I think
actually what what I want to do is let's
do a foreign exchange so what that deal
is is it'll improve our relations our
time and now if I go back to my home
planet I've given them one of my like
space bears and exchange for one of
their wolf dudes and their wolf dudes
are actually they're dumb you can see
that so they're not gonna they're not
really good scientists but they do find
it production or farming do you find
other races that just have innate likes
and dislikes of each other as you get
into the game just naturally you know
it's it's all a product of their of
their personalities which are somewhat
randomized at the beginning of the game
so yeah there though you'll see soon
that there's a lot of characterization
that goes into it they do have opinions
of each other that will be shared
through this GNN mechanic I think it
should come up pretty soon
let's just play a couple more turns and
you'll see where my ship goes it's down
here so one thing you'll notice is that
ships fleets have fuel so this is an
exploration forget it's got a lot of
fuel and as I travel outside of my
territory so my territory is this this
area here the ship's start started
eating up fuel alright so as the turns
go by their fuel gets used up okay so
this is a news robot so it's like in the
original master of Ryan to like as you
went through the game this robot would
come up and like tell you what's going
on in the galaxy so this guy yeah he'll
just pop up and give you some it's kind
of like the progress of the universe
type updates like here's what's going on
so you know who's in it who is leading
for science and like who's going to war
with who is stuff like that since like
the news broadcast from up from a highly
secret location yeah very very secure so
this is fun I like this guy alright so
we're exploring still so in terms of
expanding the reach of your race I'm
looking like the red areas here for
example that tell me how far that reach
extends is it necessary to capture these
places or there other ways to expand
your reach without necessarily
colonizing you know at this point well
you can conquer or carlin eyes that's
the I mean it's the way that you grab
new planet so far if I didn't want to
build colony ship so I could build war
fleets and send them down here and start
trying to figure out but I haven't even
scattered their territory this is early
game stuff I'm gonna send him away
there's a there's a little creep in this
miss sista and my guys unarmed so I'm
gonna run away and so I still haven't
found a good place to colonize so I'm
gonna send him back to my territory and
we'll keep poking around oh so I've seen
him all right we're gonna send him back
to the wormhole alright so now that
we're pays tribute no I'm not gonna if
we go back up in here now if we can like
recontact them you can see that like
when they asked me for tributes and I
and I declined now like you can see like
a modifier to my relationship so you
know exactly why they're mad
which you know in for our schemes is
really helpful so you know like you know
where you stand why I couldn't stand and
like civilization five before they kind
of fixed it like right you know why are
you declaring war on me I thought well
your buds you know so so now you know at
least in stardrive 20 so we're looking
basically at the this is the exploration
phase of the game so I found a planet it
looks pretty good it's like a swamp
planet I'll show you some combat so you
can kind of see where the game would go
you know 30 45 minutes from now is we
really get and get into it totally i'm
done for that so one thing i should i do
want to emphasize before we leave this
is that this this there's so much stuff
out here to find in the galaxy other
like event all kinds of weird events
that you can come stumble across we have
a ground combat mode that i might be
able to show you before the end of this
video there's an espionage system so you
can spy on your your enemies and steal
their technologies there's heroes let me
see if i can I have a system right here
so i can just cheat and give myself a
hero yeah so like you get an opportunity
to hire heroes along the way so she's a
Wing Commander so she gives bonuses to
your fighters and all she sees a good
spy like I can't afford her so you have
these characters that'll calm and like
kind of spice up your game play and
they'll appear as you know to the map
with like their unique ships and they
don't also appear in ground combat well
I then possibly see Alex when I when I
encounter another civilization some
point later yeah well you have an
opportunity to hire her right now so we
couldn't afford her but she goes into
this into this like leader pool and if I
get enough money then I can hire
otherwise she'll pop off to somewhere
else in the galaxy so we may come across
her later so also at the core of
stardrive to is a custom shipbuilding
like mini game and we'll get into it so
here is the battle arena and right now
I've just got two scenarios there's a
basically a scenario editor so you can
do a completely custom battle and then I
have but some kind of story driven
missions I've sort of play out like fire
bloom I'll show you so you're given like
a setup here's like the bad guy fleet
here's alex's ship warping in and now
like this is why I signed like firing
them this is like the style of
conversation that I really enjoyed from
that game we're like you know just have
these guys come up there talking to each
other and it gives you a little bit
impetus for like what this battle is
about he's just a dumb like wolf guy and
he's trying to like steal her cargo but
she doesn't have any oh and uh alright
so now I can see here's their setup
they've got like some missile frigates
and I really know what those guys are
doing but and I've got my ship here this
is Alex's ship and I've got a little
cash and I've got the ability to buy
some some ships here and then i also
have a cell look I could put an Aegis
frigate down for 235 sounds good right
so I spend a little bit of my money I
can also go into the market and I can
spend my cash unlocking new tech so
these are like some of the text you to
unlock in the forex mode alright so you
can go all the way down this tree but
you know here in this battle arena mode
I just give them to you so you can just
find piecemeal so weapons systems I
think I want to buy a fighter Bay so we
can get some fighters out so now I've
unlocked this fighter Bay I can that
means I'm unlocked like another ship
design that I couldn't access before
this Wells class carrier so I'll get one
of those guys I'll buy one of these big
battleships and we can go take a look at
this in the shipyard so these are like
the the holes that I'm dealing with so
that's the free ages frigate that I put
down and think here is like the wells
class carrier so what what we're looking
at here is is a is a module overlay
alright so we have the we have like the
ship and then I kind of project this
little tile basically on top of it and
then we can take all the different
modules that we've unlocked in the
market or in the forex mode if we're
playing that mode and start like putting
them down onto onto the ship and you can
see like weapons have firing arcs
depending on where you're putting them
they all have like mass power draw the
some of them use ordinance
as opposed to energy to fire cell if you
have a good disrupter cannon it just
requires power so there's this many the
kind of intense deep minigame about like
building a well-balanced ship so some of
these are this one here is an Aegis
frigate so it's meant to intercept
missiles it's got a bunch of these
little point defense laser cannons it's
got this big flat cannons that pop off
like proximity fused weapons and then
there's an ECM jammer here so it's
really useful against this enemy fleet
that I know has a lot of missiles and
then the the wells class carry me drop
down it's got three fighter Bay's and
also has some flak and then we put down
one of these big cruisers that's just
like tons of armor and a couple of
missile launchers so it's probably
pretty good fleet I can buy maybe on
more these ages frigates that'll be good
okay so then we can start the battle so
they're already like launching in like
their missiles hardcore now I can pause
it at any time to kind of get the lay of
the land I can zoom in and hit the tab
key to see the module overlay and
that'll change as it takes damage I can
see exactly what the modules taking
damage our suit and it's all like
directional fires so it's not like these
aren't abstracted things this is like
how the game views the ship so let's get
that going I've got some fighters here
I'm gonna launch the fighters out of
these guys let's try to like take these
dudes and maybe do a flanking maneuver
I'm gonna wait for their like wave of
dudes to crash up against mine my
frigates here and I will try to flank
them
so you'll see us they start to take
damage like the we'll see some of the
effects when I start really getting
messed up so these guys this guy's like
get hurt on pause it and take a look at
him so you can see you like down here as
module overlay is like turning yellow on
his various quadrants you can see
there's like a now when I pop it up like
he's just been kind of wrecked pretty
fast by my my dudes butt back here
they've got these missile cruisers that
are just like lobbing in ordnance like
untouched so I got to do something about
that so I'm gonna take these these
fighters try to get get around him I'll
see what I can do so I think these guys
will be able to withstand that Mirage
think I'm also gonna
just get it moving up there
so this battle that will shield yeah
he's shielded but they can get inside
the shield bubble too he'll knock the
shield's out pretty quick I think he
doesn't have a ton of shields let's see
but this battle that we're playing here
it's it's pretty representative of what
you'll play in the campaign mode except
it's just you can just jump right in you
don't have to like spend the hours
building an empire to go like get at it
and and you can build your own to that's
like me I said I gave like a custom ship
our custom what's the call like a level
editor here so you can just build your
own really easily i'll show you that
before we put out yeah looks like we're
really doing it couldn't quite well
actually i would say your it's almost
like i built this thing but did you
build it on rock and roll yeah I built
it on coffee so did you ever because of
course this isn't an ambitious enough of
an undertaking did you ever consider
doing something like a like battles and
actual like obviously it's it's in three
it's it's it's it's in 3d but more or
less takes place on a 2d plane if you
look consider doing a homeward homework
Neelu try that again a homeworld style
kind of full 3d combat totally aced them
yeah I mean I I decided it was complex
enough you know there's already a lot to
this game I don't want to ski it's like
it's pretty hardcore as is i don't want
to scare people off i really try and
make this game so like everyone can
enjoy 4x maybe people who don't even
like know the John Riggs is right you
know homeworld is an awesome game and
maybe someday I will do something like
that but as it stands this is this is
fun probably for the best yeah so at the
end of this mission we were successful
you know Alex didn't die now you can
like you know we're getting a stress
call there's like a whole other mission
that we can lead into so let's click
through this dialogue and now now we get
some we can see our after-action report
if our ships do really well together in
commendations
that will affect their performance in
the future so and these are persistent
through the 4x mode and through the
battle arena mode we didn't hurt any
metals here okay and the units as well
continue through this yeah this is line
of so here's like all the units I had
before oh I've got somebody on Steam
saying hi and he did nope go away so
this battle I need to protect this this
star system a skier and they've got a
much bigger fleet but now I have a
little bit extra money so I heard some
money at the end of that battle and we
can keep playing career sure so um and
then we can go back exit the arena side
I gave you this scenario editor here so
people can just basically just have at
it make their own battles with all
anything they want because there's all
kinds of really really great like
great-looking ships to play with
suddenly they're looking a lot more
intimidating yeah yeah those are some
really cool [ __ ] i always want to get
too close to one of those karate command
ship how do i do this with my Mac I
don't know with the control Kiyosaki
there's all right
so you can just create like whatever
battle scenario on just go at it so you
know if I think a lot of people who like
these games are really into really into
trying out new builds and stuff like
before you before you do it in the
actual campaign mode totally and I
really hope to be able to integrate this
with a steam workshop right now it's all
like XML base so it's like really easy
for people to share and I just got to
work with the steamy API to get it like
all integrated there so I hope it's
super model so like you know if you want
to create your own like heroes if we saw
Alex in that last mission in argh you
know so you can like import your own
graphics and everything and I've got
that all built into the scenario editor
so yeah that's basically they're all I
have to show right now the game is I
mean a games feature complete so you're
gonna have a steam key and you should
hopefully dig in and have a good time
with it there's also a ground combat
mode that you know we have to actually
kind of earn your way there in the game
before you see it give me questions
about it yeah so first of all win a star
drive to gonna be available for
everybody when I want to buy this game
and it's complete ready to go q1 I mean
we're looking at there's no snow secrets
I really want to get it out in February
there's just right now there's kind of
logistical stuff we gotta deal with to
getting out there something setting up
for a steam store page and like liaison
with them about like the exact release
day getting our trailer ready so there's
all kinds of that stuff the game is
pretty much ready to go it's all the
other stuff I gotta drive and in terms
of player interactions it looks it looks
all single player to me right now with
that is that single player going for
yeah I mean I I built this game there's
11 designer one programmer is me and I
bit off a lot already and I had to chew
that up I can't I can't also do
multiplayer I think with you know really
sit like this millennium but maybe in
the future I really want to have it
multiplayer alright well Daniel I'm I'm
grateful for you coming by i'm really
looking forward to playing star drive to
give me that key quickly please uh and
but but in the meanwhile obviously stay
tuned the game spot for more cool stuff
and hopefully more cool stuff on star
drive to ya come
we'll we'll look forward to seeing this
hopefully in February but will say q1 q1
okay thanks dad
you